التحقيق مع ابن الرئيس الامريكي هنتر
بايدن وعد قطعه قاده بارزون في الحزب
الجمهوري بعد يوم واحد من ضمان الاغلبيه
في مجلس النواب وعد يبدو ان موعد الوفاء
به قد حان حيث حددت لجنه الرقابه في
الكونجرس برئاسه النائب جيمس كومر بعد
غدنا الجمعه موعدا لاولى جلسات استجواب
نجل الرئيس جو بايدن الذي لطالما كان هدفا
مفضلا لدى الجمهوريين فيما يتعلق بانشطته
التجاريه وبعمله السابق مع الشركات
الاجنبيه تقارير امريكيه ذكرت ان نوابا من
الحزب الجمهوري يتهمون نجل بايدن باستغلال
النفوذ وباداره ممارسات تجاريه دوليه غير
قانونيه حقق من خلالها مليارات الدولارات
ورقه ضغط جديده للجمهوريين على الرئيس جو
بايدن سيتم من خلالها اجراء مجموعه شامله
من التحقيقات في المعاملات الماليه لابنه
ها حيث سيكون التحقيق احد اهم اولويات
اللجنه التي لديها تفويض واسع للنظر في
المخالفات المزعومه وخرق القانون المحتمل
والكشف عن المستندات المصرفيه لهنتر بايدن
المعروفه باسم تقارير الانشطه التجاريه
المشبوهه اللجنه المكلفه بالتحقيق مع
هانتر تقول انها تواجه الكثير من الحواجز
من طرف وزاره الخزانه التي تعيق الطلبات
حيث ردت الاخيره بالنفي